Amy Klobuchar she's largely become  irrelevant she was on Meet the Press  with Chuck Todd here they are talking  about censorship big Tech and what we  should do about all of you people who  say things that they don't like do you  think if you open these company UPS  companies up to lawsuits do you think  their behavior would change yes because  then in order to continue they have to  put safety measures in place their  argument is Big tech companies are not  doing enough to silence you so you have  a giant news organization NBC News  calling for the Silence of people and  why would they do that because they want  the Monopoly on information but they  keep telling you they're worried about  is misinformation and disinformation but  if we were to go through the Litany of  things that Chuck Todd and NBC News at  CNN in Washington posted everywhere else  has lied about over the last couple  years they would all be banning  themselves and suing themselves into  Oblivion and much more